nun habe ich auf einem kanal schon
wirklich einige tester dem online geld
zu verdienen bezahlte umfragen fiber
bitcoin mining twitch stream online
poker aktienhandel und vieles mehr heute
habe ich erfahren dass man auch also
fürs zocken bezahlt werden gibt's nicht
denkt ihr euch jetzt vielleicht doch
gibt es und so funktioniert es gibt in
unserem vereinfachten beispiel drei
parteien die geld ab den nutzer also
mich und die entwickler des spiels das
wir spielen werden die geld ab sagt
jetzt zu dem entwickler hey ich kann der
neue nutze beschaffen wenn du mir dafür
geld gibst dir dann sagt die geld app
zum nutzer also mir hey du bekommst du
mir etwas geld wenn du dieses spiel
download ist und eine weile spielstil
aber was hat nun der entwickler davon
naja zum einen wird ein spiel durch
meinen download im app store höher
gelistet und zum anderen besteht die
chance dass ich zwar nicht vorhabe aber
dass der nutzer langfristig bei seinem
spiel bleibt und in app käufe getätigt
oder werbung schaut aber lohnt sich dass
ich meine es ging ja schon bis hin zu
schön um wahr zu sein für die nächsten
48 stunden werde ich jetzt also nichts
tun außer videospiele zu spielen und
herausfinden wie viel ich dafür bezahlt
werde und vor allem ob ich überhaupt
gezahlt werde und wie lange es dauert
bis das geld auf meinem konto spaß
funktioniert die geld mit fünf sternen
und extrem viel wertungen dann kann sie
eigentlich nur gut sein würde ich sagen
okay 30 credits als geschenk 110 play
state of the wall will komplett
kurslevel 21 für die hmi kriegen 17.600
alter das wären ja schon über zehn euro
das wären tatsächlich fast 15 euro komm
ich ziehe das durch startaufgabe wobei
ich auch dass es das spiel für das ich
immer so richtig eklige werbung gekriegt
hat jetzt haben sie mich doch gekriegt
haben wir lohnt sich das da kann ich
meine eigenen planungsstab eigentlich
auch ein schmeißen um neue user zu
kriegen selbst wenn ich jetzt wirklich
die ganzen zwei tage brauchen würde nur
um das zu kriegen zwei tage lang 0 15
euro ist halt nicht auch schon nordbad
wir fragen jetzt wie lange muss ich das
jetzt überhaupt spielen hätte wurde
level 21 das ding ist jetzt level 4 muss
mich häufig dauert wieder ohne probleme
ein anderes vielleicht gibt es auch
leichter angebot
ok hier muss ich nur der wirt 2
erreichen das klingt ich viele den
ganzen abend über das rita spiel und bin
auf einem guten weg level 2 zu erreichen
glaube ich zumindest
denn aufgrund der schlechten übersetzung
in der manier bin ich mir nicht 100
sicher was gewollt ist und was sich
überhaupt tun muss um weitere gegner zu
besiegen brauche ich sechs ausdauer
leider regeneriert sich nur ein ausdauer
pro sechs minuten das heißt ich kann
mich außer ich gebe echtgeld aus
versteht sich nur alle 36 minuten zu
meinem ziel vorkämpfen bei dem ich
ausgezahlt werde hoffentlich bevor ich
jetzt noch mehr teil rennstrecke will
ich erstmal mit einer mini kurzen
aufgabe testen ob die credits überhaupt
gutgeschrieben werden wenn ich etwas
erledigen oder ob ich komplett über den
tisch gezogen werde und diesmal wird mir
auch klar warum die app so gute
bewertungen hat ein angebot bei dem man
100 credits bekommt nur für einen klick
auf die fünf- sterne- und siehe da die
belohnung hat uns erreicht fünf sterne
verdient die app bisher aber noch nicht
also ändere ich das ganz schnell wieder
zurück auf einen stern
die belohnung bleibt als nächstes an
scheinbar kurzes clips wie viele würfel
sind in diesem bild was ist der
meistgespielte song auf spotify die
fragen sind zuerst sehr leicht und bei
den schweren fragen am ende kugelig die
lösung einfach ich bin ja nicht um
trotzdem nur 70 prozent richtig aber
wenn ich dieses nächste drei minuten
kurs absolvieren kann ich die fehlenden
punkte nachholen und bekommen trotzdem
eine belohnung okay es sind ja nur drei
minuten obwohl rechts oben steht
massiven report nichts immer noch 130
credits tägliche belohnung abgeholt 20
credits werde gefragt ob ich werbung
schauen will für mehr credits willich
crypto werbung keine belohnung toll ich
mache noch eine weile weiter mental geht
es mir richtig schlecht es ist spät naja
vielleicht gibt's morgen bessere
aufgaben die ändern sich nämlich
tatsächlich regelmäßig und vielleicht
kann ich mir dann meinen bonus holen mit
der angesparten ausdauer in der ritter
weiter geht's am neuen job da kann man
sich auch mal raus setzen was unfällen
danke für den support hoffentlich dazu
ja cool genau klick eigentlich in diesem
game auch nur sachen an die haben
irgendwie wie gesagt hell aufleuchten
wird extrem viel ausdauer und mit diese
ausdauer kann ich jetzt hoffentlich bis
level zwei vorkämpfen
wenn man eine belohnung ankommen weil
ich will jetzt nicht unbedingt mein
leben dann geht es eine spielen die
kämpfe sind auch relativ kurios weil es
passiert einfach automatisch man kann
absolut nichts da irgendwie beeinflussen
man kann manchmal auf irgendeinen
leuchtenden knopf draufdrücken dann
machte eine spezialattacke aber
ansonsten sieht alles alleine visuell
sind aber schöner oder so wenn man das
heißt auch steuern könnten dann künstler
schon fast für die spaß machen hier zu
kämpfen das härteste letzte gewesen
da kommt noch mehr montierte baum 2 ist
der stufe 2 ist ein gegner stufe 2 ist
dass das was wir noch machen müssen
bevor wir aufhören können hier gibt's
sogar ein youtube-video darüber hast ja
geil ich muss die academy und dann
monster handbuch leveln hätte man früher
machen sollen damit ich die ganzen fahrt
habe ich schon eine academy ihre monster
ok monsterjagd level 1 forschung
fertigstellen ich habe ein bisschen von
der prämie
das klingt aber plausibel also das
klingt so als könnte ich das heute
bringt jetzt erstmal warten hier ist ein
angebot bei dem man einfach sich nur
anmelden muss und sonst gar nix und
schon hat man eine belohnung gab es
überhaupt stimmt herzlichen glückwunsch
nutzer sind sind eine der sieben
personen die für die teilnahme am
programm
p ja aber jetzt bin ich doch gar nicht
ob ich das noch mal drehen cool ja
mai von 12 ja nicht funktionieren so
also theoretisch sollte ich jetzt sollte
sollte das jetzt mal gehen soll das
angeblich acht stunden aber ich weiß
nicht wieso aber kann die ganze block
hilfe klicken dann kommen nämlich leute
aus
dann dauert plötzlich nicht mehr so
lange genau jetzt also noch 40 minuten
ich habe den level 2 1 0,0 1 prozent
leben abgezogen das dauert noch wochen
bis ich den kollegen wie sie gewartet da
stand doch ich muss sie nur angreifen
das war niemals gehabt tatsächlich die
2500 fans bekommen aber das ging jetzt
relativ flott hat mich nur einen halben
tag gedauert genau jetzt muss ich nur
noch noch mal so viel regen und dann
kann ich überprüfen habe ich das geld
auch wirklich auf mein konto krieg als
nächstes entscheide ich mich dazu ein
farm spiel zu spielen welches ähnliches
spiel mechanismen hat wie die anderen
mobile games wartezeiten künstliche
verknappung von spielfunktionen und
sogar ein casino aber immerhin soll es
3840 credits geben wenn ich level 16
erreicht also spiele ich bis spätabends
und wechsel in den wartezeiten immer
wieder zum zombie spiel vom anfang das
sogar 17.600 credits also 13 euro 50
bringt wir uns gerade schlappe 230 bin
in einer endlosschleife gefangen ist es
wirklich die komplette verdummung das
macht wirklich aber permanent es macht
permanent einfach ein christ bietungen
diese ganze branche ist ich mache alles
um herauszufinden ob ich hier
draufklicken kann und wie die fünf
europa sichern kann nicht jetzt ist es
fertig gute nacht
wenn ich jetzt nicht alles täuscht bin
ich gleich level 16 16 bin dann kann ich
das endlich mal okay so level 16
glückwunsch neues level cool ja schön
aber was wir besser ist kann hier
aufhören wenn ich jetzt zurück zur manie
fg müsste ich jetzt die 2500 dinge
kriegen oder sind sie sogar dagegen
sogar mehr als gedacht tue ich dachte
ich das war okay das war mir als kind
auch vielleicht noch ein paar andere
sachen in die nach geld tragen wurden
die ich eigentlich schon lange gemacht
habe dann ist jetzt tatsächlich der
moment der wahrheit fünf euro paypal
steht jetzt eigentlich deswegen will ich
sagen kann wieder auftreten und schauen
ob sich das alles gelohnt mit und hat
sich jetzt trotzdem ich das auch wenn es
funktioniert aber dann würde ich mich
wenigstens ein bisschen weniger
verarscht vorkommen
deswegen in europa okay der paypal konto
an
mach mal glück wollen stehen
auszahlungen auftrag ist erfolgreich
eine e-mail wird die fertigstellung in
drei tagen zu bestätigen dauert es bis
zu drei tage vielleicht geht ja auch
schneller da steht er bist dann heißt es
warten im endeffekt habe ich jetzt 40
credits für zwei mal täglich locken
bekommen 100 für die bewertung 2560
dafür gegen einen level 2 monster und
3840 dafür level 16 in der geld geilsten
farm app aller zeiten zu erreicht haben
nur ein witz dieser apps und alle
geldgeilen ich habe übrigens auch 1120
credits für ein hörbuch probemonat und
800 credits für die testversion einer
virenschutz app bekommen wofür ich meine
kreditkarte angeben und danach direkt
das probe abo kündigen musste aber die
6500 credits für die fünf euro
auszahlung hätte ich auch ohne das
geschafft bisher ist es geld übrigens
noch nicht angekommen der bezahlung
status ist noch ausstehen ich glaube
aber dass mich das geld durchaus
erreichen wird genau wie in dem video in
dem ich mal die bezahlten umfragen
getestet habe wo es halt einfach noch
zwei drei tage länger gedauert aber ich
werde euch auf jeden fall in meinem
instagram in der story am laufenden
halten sobald das geld angekommen ist
damit ihr der gewissheit haben also
geschaut da gerne mal vorbei vielleicht
wurde zu dem zeitpunkt wo das video ist
und dann kommen ja schon überwiesen aber
hat er sich jetzt gelohnt
naja also beim um fragen wie ruhig
immerhin
fünf euro am tag bekommen habe habe ich
ja noch das gesagt aber dafür dass man
gar keine voraussetzungen hat man sich
einfach mal eben anmelden kann und dann
einfach mal am abend eine stunde lang da
wird man ein bisschen rum tippen kann
und als sich ein schüler war mit 16 17
der waren 30 euro in der woche halt echt
viel geld wie für irgendwelche
dummheiten spiele ausgehen hätte können
aber 48 stunden in der mobile game hölle
gefangen zu sein zwischen dreister
werbung betrügerischen umfragen und
langweiligen apps das lohnt sich für
niemanden geht die verschaltung
austragen
[Musik]